temps je me demandais dans temps de
parole mais alors il ya parole donc
théoriquement un rototo
c'est pas comptabilisés à la nomma
toupet voilà non mais je demande parce
qu'ils basque hier l on a réprimé 2 j'ai
envoyé 100 mille masques en guyane
création ou la rénovation
oui mais visiblement la toujours pas
digéré l'absence de soutien de nicolas
sarkozy jean lassalle est en tête des
candidats avec lesquels les français
aimeraient partager un barbecue au
camping bon petite déception pour le
viandard communiste fabien roussel qui
n'est que cinquième de ce classement de
la merguez maïak est pas très bon ce
matin mais vous comme ont accès à manger
on va pas faire les difficiles
ouais c'est un mauvais goût dans
les banques parce qu'on a rien d'autre
comme aujourd'hui aurait fait la saveur
moisi quoi
embellir
après les pizzas buteau dit il ya une
autre grande marque que vous connaissez
bien qu'il rappelle ses produits alors
laquelle c'est la marque ferrero et si
vous avez chez vous des produits de la
marque comme kinder kinder surprise
chocobo quelques jours de pâques et bien
il vous est conseillé surtout de ne pas
les consommer et de contacter l'équipe
d'assistance à cause de suspicion de
salmonelles dans des lots fabriqués en
belgique youpi c'est bientôt pâques les
enfants découvrez nos délicieux
chocolats issus de nos usines belges et
leurs surprises
alors les enfants heureux
mais pour lindbergh astros qui bouge
souhaite de joyeuses fêtes de pâques
qu'est-ce qui se passe j'ai une mèche
non c'est bien franchement c'est
vraiment là on remercie jamais assez les
maquilleuses et coiffeuses la magie
feront de nouveau y est à deux heures du
matin locales et même fournir à la
presse
il avait quand même envie de faire une
un truc avait quelques mois oui à la
base à la base oui elle a peut être
envie et qui semblait passée qui s'est
passé tu as vu italien bas comme jésus
comme en une posture en semaine du goût
bagua fait du judo de pose comme ça qu
en mode heure là jordi ces différences
un peu plus c'est un peu plus des
mamours quand il pose en tenue de judo
c'est mieux
elle est belle cette tu cherches des
judokas les plus hautes de ta région
magoichi deyris concept reste rêve
[Musique]
ces photos vous avez envoyé à tuân non
ça c'est sûr mon instinct constat
d'accord très bien voilà dalibard voilà
en fait je lui dit en privé quand un
gars on s'intéresse et un jeudi mais a
été trouvé sur tes photos je lui ai dit
ouvertement ses des filtres bienvenue en
2002 en général bah ouais mais donc toi
voilà aujourd'hui qu'est ce que tu
aurais à dire à tuân
vous donner des clés pour canaliser son
anxiété mythique qu'il faut penser aux
dix choses par exemple qui d'ordinaire
oui nous calme oui si moi je vous dis
que pour me calmer je bois je bois je
bois je fume comme un pompier dire que
je suis foutu oui la tornade s'approche
vous le voyez ici oh mais c'est au
dessus de ma maison permettez moi
d'appeler mes enfants les enfants vous
m'entendez je veux que vous descendiez
tout de suite au sous sol et que vous
pouvez
je ne rigole pas descendez maintenant
dans la chambre au sous sol
ça arrive dans dix quinze minutes et la
loi qui nous impose de respecter le
temps de parole c'est pour cela que vous
verrez dans ce débrief emmanuel macron
des extraits de son discours qui
compenseront le temps de parole que nous
avons accordé aux autres candidats les
français peuvent éteindre leur
télévision puisqu'il n'est pas